- C'est l'image qu'on
capitale financière :
une ville modeetetet riche.
c'est ici qu'il se vit,
dans les qrsrsrsrs de logements
sociaux. 80 % des Singapouriens
résident dans ces "HDB flas s s.
Toute famille dont le revenu
annuel est inférieur à
l'équivalent de 185 000 $cicici.
Il apprécie l'aspect
communautaire.
Et il avoue aimer un peu tropl'.
de logements sociaux construits
par le gouvernement inininingap.
Ils ont remplacé les bidonvilles
et les habitations insalubres
Ces habitations on
au coeur de la modernisation
rapide du pays. La demandeevevee
que l'offre. Mais pas de guerre
de prix : c'est le gouvernement
qui établit l'ordre de priorité
Hidayed pourra emménager
dans son propre appartement
terminée dans deux ans.
Il a été jugé prioritaire,
puisque c'est sa première
propriété et que ses parents
complexe grâce au programme
incitatif multi-nenenenenenel.
Il recevra même de l'aide
gouvernementale allant
jusqu'à 50 000 $ pour
Singapour s'est récemment lancé
dans le logemedededededede luxe.
C'est ce qui menace
l'accessibilité pour lesrcrcrcr.
Car l'État vavavavavavavavavavan
dans son prix de vente,
et il est donc victime
des fluctuations du marché
ont d'ailleurs augmentéde 10 % .
Et le gouvernement a dû
im
des mesures pour freiner
la situation. Hidaye
a juste hâte d'avoir sa première
propriété avec sa conjointe
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Singapour